on the day that the Female Eunuch was
issued in America a person in flapping
draperies rushed up to me and grabbed my
hand thank you it breathed hoarsely
thank you so much for all you've done
for us girls I smoked and nodded and
stepped backward trying to extricate my
hand from the enormous knock Harry bring
and pour that clutched it the face
staring into mine was thickly coated
with a pancake and make up through which
the stubble was already in futile
competition with a Dynel wig of immense
Longhorns and two pairs of false
eyelashes against the bony ribs that
could be counted through it's flimsy
scarf dress while a polished steel
woman's iteration and more I should have
said you're a man the Female Eunuch has
done less than nothing for you
[Music]
let's go adult human females
first of all a reminder that this video
is a female only space so if there are
any men here today I mean unless you
enjoy watching the very interesting
things women do on our own
in which case like comment subscribe but
so look it's 2019 and I think most
people have heard about turfs trans
exclusionary radical feminists you know
these fanatics like Germaine Greer who
called trans women it and think trans
men are lost lesbian sisters you Meza do
know about trans men right male to
female is not the only type of
transgender person there's also people
who were born well people who were
assigned people who are always people
who identify turfs don't like being
called turfs they think it's a term of
disparagement which it is they call
themselves radical feminists rad
families or lately gender critical the
idea is that gender femininity
masculinity gender roles all that it's
all a patriarchal construct and
biological sex is the only thing that
makes a person a man or a woman in the
past on this channel i've always--
caricatured terms as being like angry
man hating bigots whose only real tactic
is accusing trans women of being creepy
man and there definitely are some people
who are really like that but i want to
be fair i want to be belongs so in
preparation to make this video i posted
an invitation to twitter asking people
who used to be gender critical feminists
to share their stories with me and i got
hundreds of responses a lot of them from
women who've had traumatic experiences
with men and who at one time found
comfort in a rigid view of gender where
women and men are completely separate
species where women are saved and men
are dangerous and for a lot of those
women allowing trans people into their
picture of the world at first challenged
their sense of stability and comfort
it was difficult emotional work work
they needed to do but still difficult
and that makes total sense to me like
it's very easy for me to understand why
someone would feel that way
so it's not just evil bigots who are
attractive to the gender critical
worldview and in this video i don't just
want to parity turfs this time I want to
really engage with gender critical ideas
in the public arena free speech open
communication dialogue conversation
debate idea marketplace expression
discourse maybe I'll even get in touch
with my inner rod
she's a little shy sure but she's here
not clear reads a lot of Germaine Greer
and when I am having a dark night of the
soul sweaty she's feeling ex extra
biological' and when the full moon
shines she speaks oh this is agony I'm a
biological woman trapped in the body of
a male narcissist
okay so she's a little out of touch sure
but she's not a bigot you know I'm sure
she doesn't hate trans people she just
has a few concerns you know it's like
you're not even allowed to ask questions
anymore or you're accused of transphobia
we're all just expected to conform to
this gender ideology that we the public
never got a chance to debate we didn't
vote for trans orthodoxy yet here we are
allowing biological males to run rampant
in women's spaces wasting penises on
lesbians and indoctrinating our children
with the ludicrous dogma that girls can
become boys with a change of costume oh
it waddles my chromosomes she goes on
like that for hours it's like being
trapped at the bottom of an elevator
shaft with a ghost of Anita Bryant do
you kids even know who Anita Bryant is
do you have any idea how many decades I
fought for your rights who doesn't need
a brain even dead scholars remain
divided it does seem like it's getting
harder to have conversations about
difficult topics you know our children
are coming of age and this Orwellian
nightmare where you can face
consequences for simply having a
politically incorrect opinion about the
Jewish Question it's PC run amok it's a
Hanukkah Tosh trophy problematic banter
aside the current discourse about
transgender issues is an explosion of
untreated sewage we have far-right
politicians menacing us with legal
discrimination and erasure
we have fear-mongering and hostility in
the press and that combined with high
rates of family rejection and
mistreatment puts trans people on the
defensive so in public we tend to stick
together concede nothing and shield
ourselves behind simple unambiguous
slogans trans women are women which is
true we are women but ooh that was a
sinister plot watch out for that what
happens is that people who don't really
understand trans issues in other words
most people have lots of unanswered
questions about the details and in
particular people who are familiar with
feminist theory but not transfeminine
might wonder things like how can you be
a woman without the oppression
experiences of grah hood
why can't
just be a feminine man instead of AK
waiting womanhood with sexist
stereotypes why our misogynistic gender
ideologues erasing the vocabulary needed
to discuss female oppression trans
people don't like engaging with these
questions because most of the time
they're just brandished as weapons
against us you know it's like when a man
asks if society is so sexist against
women then why is it that men are 97% of
combat fatalities feminazis like you
could sit there for three hours trying
to make a nuanced feminist rebuttal but
wouldn't you rather just eat a bowl of
thumbtacks because nine times out of ten
that guy doesn't give a [ __ ] about
combat fatalities he's just trolling you
to shut down whatever actual point you
are making and the same goes for people
telling me you sure do like wearing
nails and makeup is that all you think
there is to being a woman could you
define womanhood for me like they don't
actually care they're just trying to
make my life worse for 20 minutes but if
you really are sincerely wondering about
the answer to these troll questions and
many people are then you actually need
fairly complicated and nuanced answers
which is why they make such good troll
questions because they waste a lot of
your time in this video I want to take
at face value the questions and concerns
associated with gender critical
hostility to trans people and I want to
try to give nuanced answers rather than
dogmatic ones now the problem with being
nuanced is that it's hard so I might
[ __ ] something up and a lot of trans
people want me to represent them
absolutely perfectly so if I do a [ __ ]
something up well just to read me to
filth on Twitter like you always do you
little shits love you let's watch an
instructional video to learn more can a
man ever be as glamorous as a woman we
have 13 beautiful women on our show
today only the catch is that some of
them are actually men oops wrong channel
concern one gender metaphysics there is
no such thing as a man trapped in a
woman's body
there are no pink brains and blue brains
just because you want to be a woman
doesn't mean you are one this whole
sacred dogma gender identity makes no
sense
trans people will often use metaphorical
language to describe feelings that are
difficult to put into words and that's
how I understand it the trapped in the
wrong body language is there literally
is such a thing as a male soul trapped
a female body or vice-versa I personally
don't believe there is but I'm a little
biased I sold my soul to a Sudanese
businessman and all I got in return was
this shitty ketamine habit
as for brains there is some evidence
suggesting a correlation between binary
trans gender identity and cross sex
brain anatomy but the evidence really
doesn't justify claims about female
brains and male bodies or anything like
that brain differences between men and
women are statistical averages of things
like gray and white matter density not
as the term female brain implies
distinct anatomical structures like
penises and vaginas so I personally
don't believe in any gender metaphysics
at all I'm kind of an unorthodox trans
person so much for the unquestionable
dogma of the trans cult and that I think
of myself as a woman who used to be a
man rather than as always having been a
woman but it's important to remember
that while I may not fit the typical
profile I am NOT real and not valid but
in any case I live as a woman now and
that's kind of just what's happening
whether you like it or not so I'm not
sorry my view is well expressed by
Catherine McKenna I always thought I
don't care how someone becomes a woman
or a man doesn't matter to me
anybody who identifies as a woman wants
to be a woman is going around being a
woman as far as I'm concerned as a woman
concern to gender stereotypes what do
you mean you live as a woman you mean
you reinforce oppressive gender
stereotypes by putting on nails makeup
and a fake girly vice listen sweaty
first of all my girly voice is very
[ __ ] real second my clothes make up
voice none of this makes me a woman no
trans woman thinks that femininity and
womanhood are the same rather we're
using a cultural language of feminine
signifiers to prompt others to see us
for what we are sometimes I get the
impression that my sister all friends
don't really understand why I'm
presenting in such a meticulously
feminine way like they think I'm wearing
ombre lips at 11:00 a.m. because I'm
playing some kind of cloud game which I
am but also if one person calls me sir
that's gonna ruin my day
so I'm desperately throwing glitter
spaghetti at the wall and hopes the
light catches some glimmer of womanhood
I think butch are gender non-conforming
since women sometimes sight I
hyper-feminine trans women because they
don't identify with this vision of
womanhood at all and they've had a
struggle since childhood against a
society that's told them they have to be
feminine and I completely sympathize her
thought I think there should be more
gender freedom less coercion less
restriction but also I have had to fight
against the same society that told me I
should really really really not be this
so I feel like we should be able to form
some kind of solidarity here one concern
three abolish gender but you should be
moving beyond the patriarchal constructs
of masculinity and femininity not
conforming to them real feminism aims to
abolish gender not reinforce it abolish
gender well that sounds like an
ambitious project for one transsexual
but I mean I'll give it a try Sylvanas
be praised no nails no makeup I'm
wearing a nice little gender-neutral
robe moment I did it everyone I
abolished gender well I guess long hair
is still a gender signifier so I should
probably get rid of that see the feeling
a little position my body is still
gendered and there's a gendered cadence
to my voice so what I'm gonna do is just
hold my hands up genderless Lee and
speak in a genderless robot voice my
name is 5 4 6 6 4 1 7 I have no gender
patriarchy is over I guess English is
still patriarchal language right so I
should probably be communicating with a
series of genderless sounds I can't
stand this [ __ ] this look maybe a
polishing gender is a good idea like
wouldn't it be better if your genitals
at Birth didn't determine what kind of
life you could live but that is a
utopian project requiring massive
systemic change
kind of like abolish borders your
utopian pipe dream is valid and denying
trans people their gender identity
because a bullish gender is kind of like
denying citizenship to immigrants
because abolish borders like you're
targeting the people who are the most
vulnerable under the present system and
then leveraging that system against them
under the pretense of abolishing it you
know you don't see gender critical
feminists and Kim Kardashian's Instagram
comments like are you wearing a dress
Kim you creepy misogynist you should be
abolishing gender not reinforcing
stereotypes designed to oppress women oh
they don't attack the gender expression
of people with power and influence
they're all on Twitter harassing some
poor newly out trans women with 200
followers and
calling her a creepy man and mocking her
for being feminine ineptly
or being too feminine or not being
feminine enough it's almost like when
they say abolish gender what they really
mean is abolish trans people it's almost
like this is a hate movement hiding
behind a handful of pseudo feminist
platitudes but surely I must be missing
something your concern for male
privilege it is absolutely typical of
male privilege and entitlement but you
think you can just claim womanhood for
yourself without living any of the
struggle that entails so look I'm a
successful white middle-class trans
woman and the grand scheme of things I'm
really not very oppressed I may not be
the 1% but I am the [ __ ] 1% so I don't
like to complain about every little
micro aggression I experience because
under the circumstances it just seems a
little gauche and I don't like things
that are goes but I've has his feminists
of my race and class tell me that I have
no idea what it's like to be talked over
and interrupted by men actually
Kropotkin or to experience street
harassment or to have to treat every
first date like a potentially
life-threatening situation and it's just
bizarre to me that they think that like
what do you think my experience in the
world is you think men treat me as their
equal you think Street harasser they're
gonna treat me with dignity and respect
because I have a Y chromosome hey
beautiful
where are you going baby where you going
oh it's training excuse me sir my
mistake please proceed freely to your
destination come on people use your
heads when you have a Germaine Greer
calling trans woman it what do you think
the guy in the steps of the liquor store
is gonna say when a trans woman doesn't
pass it's not like society simply treats
her like a man no you get treated his
monster gender pronouns it and spit and
male privilege is not a good description
of that experience at all once you start
passing as a woman it's really a step up
even though women get treated bad
because it's still better to be a she
than an it now gender critical feminists
are really skeptical of the whole notion
of
passing they think they can always clock
at ran and they assume everyone else can
too but that's just not reality
I mean I'm only a year and a half into
my transition and at this point if had
zero surgeries and it's been like six
months since I was last misgendered off
line I mean a person with a good eye for
it will probably clock me and maybe a
lot of people have just been
indoctrinated into politically correct
gender ideology but like you really
think the gas station attendant and the
nail technicians and the heating and
plumbing guy are all calling me miss and
man because of post-modernism I know
some of you were gonna sneak off to your
shitty little rad femme forums and
obsess over how may only unclog Obul I
am but like at the end of the day what
am I going to trust the deranged hate
posting of 25 frothing Ananse or every
social interaction I've had for months
I'm so sorry you can't handle it I'm
natural fish I'm ahi tuna and your
mackerels 20 take a [ __ ] sip babes
concern 5 male socialization so you had
a male upbringing you've never
experienced the traumas of girlhood you
benefited from male privilege for
decades and now you think none of that
matters you are who you are because of
how you were socialized not because of
how you dress alright it's time to crack
open the nuanced so in the one hand
you're partially right I have no idea
what it's like to be cat cold as a 9
year old girl or what that does to a
child's psyche that kind of thing
doesn't start happening to me till I was
an adult when I knew what I was getting
into and was ready for it that's very
different from what sis women go through
my upbringing and adolescence has more
in common with a typical man than a
typical woman and many of my experiences
from those days I simply can't make
sense of as female experiences I
absolutely benefited from male privilege
and it did influence who I was and who I
was in my late teens and early 20s was
an anti-feminist [ __ ] who had no
idea what women go through and I feel
ashamed and alone in admitting that
because in trans discourse it's just
accepted it's obvious that trans men
know what it's like to be raised as
women and to be influenced by those
formative female experiences but when it
comes to the early life experiences of
trans women we're supposed to say when I
was five years old I loved wearing my
mom's high heels or else say nothing at
all there's that wonderful quotation
from
the applause where she described as the
way living as a woman stifles an
adventurous spirit and her longing for
male experience yes my consuming desires
to mingle with road crews sailors and
soldiers barroom regulars to be part of
a scene anonymous listening recording
all this is spoilt by the fact that I am
a girl a female always supposedly in
danger of assault and battery my
consuming interest in men and their
lives is often misconstrued as a desire
to seduce them or as an invitation to
intimacy yes god I want to talk to
everybody as deeply as I can I want to
be able to sleep in an open field to
travel west to walk freely at night so I
got to do all that my early 20s and what
I discovered is I hate sleeping in open
fields I despise the West and I'd really
rather stay inside collecting ceramics
and sucking dick now I'm not saying that
makes me a woman and I'm not saying that
Sylvia Plath is a man because she wanted
to slam back brewskis with road crews
for reasons that are inconceivable to me
what I am saying is that when I hit my
mid-20s I realized that I was inhabiting
a gender body and sexual persona that
were drastically wrong for me and I
tried every possible alternative to
transitioning before realizing that I
had an irrepressible need to become a
woman so I changed and when I changed
society's treatment of me changed
socialization doesn't end with childhood
it's a lifelong process for example when
I transitioned my friends family fans
enemies stalkers and radical feminist
haters started commenting on my physical
appearance about 20 to 30 times more
often and I had to get used to that
being something that matters a lot more
that said resocialize ation takes time
and sometimes trans people who are early
in transition have most of that process
ahead of them I also think we have to
take into account the age at which a
person transitions Kym Patras the most
we Stan Lee's do I stand
always idea she transitioned as a child
and I imagined was socialized
more or less the same as
woman whereas Caitlyn Jenner host well
just him
she made millions of dollars in men's
sports she had six children by three
wives she transitioned in retirement at
age 65 and told BuzzFeed that the
hardest part of being a woman is
figuring out what to wear this is the
only trans woman most people have heard
of it makes me want to cry like I'm not
saying that Caitlyn Jenner isn't a woman
but I am saying that anyone who wants to
argue that male priviledge hasn't shaped
her perspective doesn't have a leg to
stand on but also trans women often
don't experience male socialization the
way sis men do many trans women are
feminine and queer before they
transition and have always experienced a
kind of femmephobia that is rooted in
misogyny some trans women also
identified as women years before
transitioning and internalized society's
messaging about women more than
society's messaging about man
now the still not the same as living in
society as a girl from birth but it's
also pretty different from the
socialization of most assess man I think
the reason some trans women feel the
need to argue that trans women never
experience male privilege is that a lot
of turfs use male privilege as a proxy
for calling us men pull up your zipper
your male privilege is hanging out I
suspect the reason this is such a major
talking point for many gender critical
feminists is that there's an element
here of stolen valor the sense of
injustice that people are claiming their
identity without experiencing their
oppression it reminds me of what in the
trans community are called trans medical
assist the only real trans people or
those who experience agonizing dysphoria
in both cases there's a sense that the
essential thing that confirms your
identity is pain what it is to be trans
is to despise your body what it is to be
a woman is to be brutalized by men you
didn't suffer like I've suffered you
don't know what it's like you know I'm
tempted to strike back by saying that
you don't know it is like to occupy an
identity so stigmatized that most of the
people who are attracted to you in
private are too ashamed to admit it in
public you don't know what it's like to
have a body so non normative that you're
shut out of whole areas of society I
could go on but this America's next top
victim contest does nothing but to
provoke infighting between trans women
insists women at a time when we should
be marching side-by-side to destroy
video games forever hashtag yes all
gamers
while a concern sex reproductive
oppression you don't know what it's like
to grow up being ashamed for your
periods to fear unwanted pregnancies you
have to fight for your right to abortion
to bear the pain of childbirth well yeah
that's true my inner rod fem sways and a
gentle victorious samba I do think it's
important for trans women to stand in
solidarity with sis women on issues like
period equity and abortion rights and to
learn about the experiences assist women
to form a more complete understanding of
the female condition but of course no
individual woman experiences all the
things women experience and individual
women understand the meaning of
womanhood in drastically different ways
for some women having babies is the most
essentially woman the experience for
others maybe it's having an abortion I
mean not actually but you know turfs
pretend it is down the [ __ ] for me
it's receiving 12 paragraph emails in my
business inbox from married men
struggling through the existential
crisis of some kind of [ __ ] themed
sexual awakening also do you want to be
a gust to my podcasts free speech radio
but also not all women experienced their
womanhood is essentially oppressive or
centered around the pain of reproductive
capacity when Shania Twain's saying man
I feel like a woman she wasn't talking
about having a coat hanger abortion in
the bathroom of a Greyhound station in
Chattanooga man I feel like [ __ ] at
seven erasing female vocabulary trans
activists are erasing the vocabulary
needed to discuss women's bodies and
women's oppression you're now expected
to talk about pregnant people and
immense traitors just to appease the
gender ideologues
well I for one am NOT a menstruate er I
am a WOM B Y n and I will not be erased
okay if you've heard the terms men
straighter or pregnant people and are
thinking what the [ __ ] kind of Orwellian
Newspeak gender cuckoldry is that take a
deep breath clear mind here's the team
some medical organizations have recently
begun using the term pregnant people
instead of pregnant women and in 2016
Planned Parenthood included the word men
Streeters in a tweet about the repeal of
a tampon tar
this has prompted some conservative turf
and Christian publications to post
panicked commentaries warning that the
entire concept of womanhood is being
erased but in fact medical language that
assume is that everyone with a uterus is
a woman erases trans men or non-binary
people who menstruate and get pregnant
so Saeng pregnant women in this context
erases them whereas saying pregnant
people includes them anthesis women and
doesn't erase anyone except for
Cincinnatians because we all know there
are not people take your shitty chile
elsewhere have a woman not a god damn
men straighter what kind of misogynistic
madness is it to reduce women to their
capacity to bleed I actually agree with
you that the word men straighter sounds
pretty humanizing and the trans men I've
talked to about this aren't the biggest
fans of it either so notice it takes a
while to settle on language that's both
inclusive and usable and my prediction
is that men straighter is is not gonna
work out maybe people who men straight
but I can't I just say woman that's what
I am you can't just say woman that is
what you are no one is asking that you
stop referring to yourself as a woman
institutional medical language is
designed to be inclusive and therefore
impersonal no one is proposing that we
stop calling individual women pregnant
women or expectant mothers your obvious
misogyny is naked ly exposed I noticed
it's only female anatomy or trying to
erase I noticed you're not suggesting
doctors start saying people with
prostate so I am definitely suggesting
odd but trans activists are invading
feminist spaces in telling women we
can't discuss our own bodies I have no
problem with cysts feminists discussing
or celebrating periods or wearing [ __ ]
hats at political marches were free
bleeding all over the National Mall I
mean someone has to the National Mall is
not gonna bleed on itself I totally get
why says feminists would want to
celebrate the reproductive Anatomy and
defiance of a society the routinely
shames and subjugates them for it the
problem arises only when menstruation or
reproductive Anatomy are used to miss
gender trans men or exclude WOM homes
stuff not bleed I mean trans women do
bleed but Volney when we cut ourselves
to be a sad Tran what what concern eight
turf is a slur turf is a slur designed
to silence women nay it is hate speech
designed to incite violence against
women the word turf is a pejorative for
a person who dresses up transphobia with
radical feminism but it's not a slur a
slur is a pejorative the target
someone's race religion gender or
sexuality the word misogynist is
pejorative it has only negative
connotations and is often used as an
insult but it's not a slur it targets
bigoted behavior and beliefs not a type
of person the same is true of the word
turf it's a derogatory term for beliefs
and behaviors that deserve to be
derogated the term gender critical is
really a euphemism recently created to
replace turf with a phrase that doesn't
have such negative connotations it's
perfectly analogous to the phrase race
realist which was invented by racists
wanting a more flattering and
respectable description of their beliefs
I've used the term gender critical in
this video to be inviting to fence
sitters but I refuse to cooperate with
racists who want me to use their
euphemisms and I generally do the same
with turfs now I'm a very agreeable non
confrontational person I usually like to
call people by whatever they want to be
called but when it comes to race realist
or gender critical every time I use
these phrases I'm essentially becoming
an accomplice in their scheme to
legitimize bigotry and I have especially
little patience for turf requests for
linguistic decorum since most of the
language used by turfs is specifically
designed to be maximally hurtful harmful
and insulting to trans people for
instance turfs refer to any and all
trans related surgery as mutilation they
call trans women
Timms an acronym for trans identified
males and trans men tiffs trans
identified females obviously with the
intent of mockery and misgendering just
to give you a sample of typical turf
pros here are a couple comments from
literally the first threat I saw on the
gender critical subreddit while I was
working on this video and I have to
admit to consider
more contempt for the likes of since he
makes a point of taking selfies with
ridiculous insulting to women facial
expressions I also get a good love at
Tim's putting their hands up to their
shins they're trying to look both dainty
and to hide their Adam's apple but it
only draws more attention to their
enormous man hands I saw an AGP photo
shoot with this Neanderthal and his
fifties was posing with one leg up like
a flamingo his hands dainty Attis yeah
in every photo even group ones at events
no I was just grossed out so there it is
that's what this is really about
in this video I've gone through a list
of gender critical concerns and I've
provided responses I hope the average
person will find fair but I would be
lying to you by omission if I were to
end this video without being real with
you about what the core of the gender
critical movement is actually about see
what turfs do in public is advance what
on the surface or a series of feminist
critiques of trans people for example
the critique the hyper-feminine trans
women are reinforcing misogynistic
stereotypes designed to oppress women at
a glance this appears to be a critique
of the way some trans women behave and
present themselves but in the next
breath these same tourists will argue
that trans women are mannish unfeminine
perverts who are forcing masculinity and
two females faces so if trans women
being feminine is bad and trans women
being masculine is bad then there really
is no way that trans women could behave
the turfs would accept so in fact what
hearths really oppose is not trans women
being feminine for trans women being
masculine but trans women being trans
women in other words the fundamental
issue underlying all these phony
concerns is transphobia simple animosity
towards trans people's very existence
and it's pretty easy to recognize that
just from the tone they use when they
talk about us when you read through the
gender critical subreddit or turf
Twitter what you see is just the
flimsiest cloak of feminist platitudes
draped over a jagged thorn tangle a
visceral disgust and targeted hate the
pure exuberant malice of it all is not
even disguised in the Germaine Greer
quote from the
of this video were in the average gender
critical forum post the enormous knuckly
Harry be ringed Paul the pancake makeup
through which the stubble was already
burgeoning this Neanderthal in his
fifties ridiculous insulting to women
facial expressions now I was just
grossed out what gender critical
feminism really amounts to is a baroque
Palace of rationalizations built on a
foundation of pure disgust in this
respect it's just like homophobia you
know I came of age when gay marriage was
the most contentious social debate and
the arguments people made that marriage
was under attack that the children would
be traumatized that bestiality would be
next that this tiny minority was
undermining all our institutions with
their outrageous demands with all just
nonsense if you got a conservative drunk
as I used to be able to do Sylvia I wish
I could give you what I had he would
just blurt out the truth which was that
the sight of two grown men locking lips
made him one of vom homophobia and
transphobia do not originate in the
frontal cortex they come from the lizard
brain disgust response we evolved to
deal with blood infection vomit feces
flies the hairy paw the stubble
burgeoning through the pancake makeup
yeah it's a disgust
I can recognize at a glance because it's
the same disgust
I felt toward myself for years is the
disgust I felt when I clocked a trans
woman on the El platform in Chicago five
years ago and decided then and there to
abandon my first attempt to transition
its the disgust
I still struggle against everyday is the
disgust that's always at the bottom of
transphobia because transphobia is
always the same it always comes from the
same place and it's always expressed in
the same kinds of ways I recently
rewatched the classic viral video from
an old episode of cops where a police
officer humiliates a Native American
trans woman named Stephanie yellow hair
the power-tripping cop demands to see
her ID miss genders her dead names her
mocks her clothes and makeup and calls
her a crossdresser it's also repetitive
and familiar it's the same arsenal of
petty sadism you see in the right-wing
press on 4chan on daxing forums on
gender critical reddit it's all the same
what everyone remembers about Stephanie
yellow hair is her unbreakable wit and
confidence in the face of transphobic
abuse the single most iconic moment is
when after being grilled in the back of
the cop car amid a flurry of dead naming
and misgendering she glances back at the
cop and says excuse your beauty okay and
to that right there is the single
greatest quality of trans feminine
culture the resilience of trans women
the assumption of a regal posture and
even the most abject conditions and
that's really all you can do because
there's just no reasoning a transfer
about a bigotry so to any diehard gender
critical feminists still watching this
what else can I say except on behalf of
all trans women excuse my beauty turf
[Music]
I posted an invitation to Twitter for
people who used to be gender critical
feminists it's a shoe be in the back of
the head it's PC run a Mac Corona
premiere um turf beer choice my
chromosomes need unwind after a hard day
of the heating trans people it is
absolutely just kiss I just saw them and
I just lost it yes sir what I am a WM b
YN you know how I struggle spelling viz
Droy
[Music]
no one knows what it's like to be a sad
Tran to be a trashcan for trap chasers
chiz